e
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle a mis sur mur au dessus du berceau
une photo d'arthur rimbaud avec ses
cheveux en brosse
elle trouve qu'il est bon dans la
chambre du gosse et
déjà les petits anges sur le papier
peint je trouvais ça étrange je dis rien
elles me font marrer ses idées phoques
depuis calais
en cloque on
est ce réveil là
vous ferez des français
on rit
[Musique]
ce petit soin
de rien
[Applaudissements]
à qui c'est comme si je disais
le conseil
comme s'il existait
je me retrouve planté
tout seul
depuis qu'elle est
[Musique]
le soir elle tricote en buvant de la
merveille
des mâles c'est belote
de l'aisne elle use les miroirs à se
regarder tu en as trouvé bizarre
tout le temps
jeudi déjà les belles
oui très
à croire jo foley
c'est sur faut bien le dire
moi aussi
depuis qu'elle est
en cloque
dire maigreur
rageant
10 rossignol
quelques bonnes sections qui balance
en décembre elle ne protège
ils l'ont
le chapelet paix
elles auront du mal
white ex qui vais
c'est toi
autour du
don du carré
encore du
[Musique]
i
quand je promène mes mains l'autre côté
x200 comme des coups de poing ça bouge
je lui dis tu es un jardin
le ruisseau alors elle devient
qui parfois ce qui me désole et sa
grange regards sont
il vient c'est que même si je donnais
peiné
on ne sait jamais
en plaques
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]